from peak Tov
just Pete off comes a solemn reminder
that no matter what happens with a new
Wonder Woman the bar for female led
superhero movies it's really really low
Catwoman before you see the best DC has
to offer revisit the worst in this
sloppily directed insanely edited
[Applause]
[Music]
terribly written ridiculously acted pile
of cat barf that came out just one year
before Batman Begins but feels more like
the spiritual sequel to Batman and Robin
beat Selina Kyle just kidding this movie
has nothing to do with the source
material meet some random lady named
patience Phillips a graphic designer
with two of film's horniest co-workers
we have our way of smooth no sandwich
twelve O'Clock she's supposed to be a
frumpy nerd but since Halle Berry is the
exact opposite of that they'll just bury
her in plus size clothes and make her
super clumsy everything will change when
a cat French kisses her dead body on a
pile of garbage patients will become
Catwoman a woman with the literal powers
of a cat like hissing getting off -
Tecna
and eating disgusting amounts of tuna
but instead of oh I don't know seeing a
doctor about any of this
she'll dis Gogol the phrase cats period
women and give herself a haircut watch a
film that takes a step forward in
representing a female superhero take
eight steps back by having her do battle
against moisturizer Evo moisturizer as
cosmetics exec Sharon Stone gets to vent
some of her personal frustrations with
Hollywood I was everything they wanted
me to be and then I turned 40 they threw
me away while releasing a product that's
a class-action lawsuit waiting to happen
stop using it and you're faced you know
I'm pretty sure that product gets
recalled without Catwoman doing anything
she could literally sit her own movie
out and nothing would change revisit an
era where superheroes hit their low
poised full of iconically crappy moments
like the playground scene the emo dance
and the bat credit card never leave the
cave without it but not to be outdone
Catwoman makes its contribution to
garbage culture in the weirdest game of
basketball ever filled while they just
stand there dribbling for each other
that's not how basketball works stop
shaking your ass at him kids are
watching aah
why so look out boys cuz this ain't the
superhero movie for you and step back
girls because it's not for you either
or you Batman fans or you person with
eyes and ears this is a movie made for
no one about nothing that never should
have existed whose only positive
contribution to the world was Halle
Berry's Razzie speech she's a good sport
about it now just apologize for that
toad line and we're good you know what
happens to a toad when it's struck by
lightning
the same thing that happens to
everything else story Puss in Boots the
bread in the cat Basic Instinct macaw -
and The Lion King
hello sh t
hey it's not like Marvel was doing much
better at this point either remember
this name taser face you blow I'll do
the fingering what happens to a toad
when it's struck by lightning same thing
that happens to everything else we're
the hustlers keep them chickens at
goodbye Mr Bond